Michelle Williams is opening up about
raising her daughter Matilda without
Matilda's father the late Heath Ledger
it's all surreal it's all very very
surreal
the actress tells Porter magazine she's
a believer in not fighting circumstances
and accepting where you are and where
you've been in all senses but one quote
I would be able to go totally down that
line of thinking were it not from
Matilda not having her dad you know
that's just something that doesn't I
mean it just won't ever be right
Michelle says being a single mom is a
learning process and admit she didn't
expect to be dating at 36 with an 11
year old the star spoke briefly about
Hearn Heath's daughter with et at the
premiere of her latest film Manchester
by the sea you got dressed for the
carpet do you run any of your outfits by
Matilda just she get to say okay mommy
this is a pretty one like does she get
to weigh in in it is it a mom daughter
process no if it was up to her I think
it'd be a lot sparkly really
you